it's all kicking off just in the brakes
here well welcome back it's day two of
The Sensational lockdown leaks which
have power pressure on disgraceful my
health secretary Matt Hancock today's
files revealed then education secretary
Gavin Williamson the man who was fired
three times imagine how bad you've got
to be to achieve that Accolade a blasted
teacher unions for looking for excuses
not to work during the pandemic Hancock
called them Absolute asses which is
pretty ironic coming from him uh well
because I can reveal one absolute ass
Hancock and his own top team were about
me
I still do this first in May 2020
I got covered symptoms and I took a
covid test and so I tweeted this to say
until I get the results back and I get
the all clear I can't do Good Morning
Britain Hancock immediately tweeted his
team with an opportunity he wrote them
saying tempting as it is I probably
shouldn't comment on this but if you
collie's pointing out kindly that he can
only have a test because of the ramp up
of testing in the past week would be
good so it's beneficial for him if you
wish me well an advisor wrote you should
tweet him best wishes totally straight
wish him all the best and hope he's okay
be really classy and then get others to
point out how classy you're being and
that's exactly what Matt Hancock did
if you test positive I sincerely hope is
mild he tweeted me publicly
and other people praised him for being
so classy he and that wasn't his
intention at all
and a series of forwarding Hancock
followers Julie congratulated his
commendable maturity exactly as he and
his team planned
classy stuff well in March of the
following year this actually gets better
by which time Matt Hancock had presided
over one of the worst cover responses of
any of this of the wealthiest countries
in the world I've left my job at good
morning Brent we just discussed that you
already know the story we've just been
debating him what I didn't know until
today is that the health secretary Mr
Hancock on the then social care Minister
Alan weightly during a deadly pandemic
they saw an opportunity here as well
Helen waitley messaged in what's in the
WhatsApp group to Matt Hancock how about
we celebrate the departure appears at or
after our team meeting tomorrow p.m just
a thought Hancock replied with one word
perfect
would it be wouldn't it if they'd had a
big party to celebrate me losing my job
after actually holding people like those
two to such vigorous account for the
previous year only one problem if they
did have that party we don't know
lockdown restrictions at the time would
have meant that that kind of party to
celebrate me losing my job would have
been strictly prohibited illegal and the
people that made that law would have
been them
well joining me now is our very own
Isabel oakshot who got that Sensational
scoop I talked to be presenter Richard
Tice who probably has known about a
scoop longer than most of us and
political journalist Ava Santino is
still with us struggling with I think is
a burgeoning cold which if you give it
to me means you won't be back on the
show for at least six calendar months
um neither will you by the looks of how
unwell she is
um
fascinating little insight just
involving me in these things not
significant by any means compared to all
the other significant stuff but
interesting into their mindset about how
they just were spinning everything and
how jubilant they were to get someone
who was calling them out on a lot of
their nonsense uh repeatedly getting
what they saw as is due comeuppance I
mean I did a search for your name today
peers and I have to say that um there
were so many mentions of you that I had
to give up trying to pull them all out
and look they were frankly obsessed by
you
um they were continually wondering what
to say to you to keep you in the place
that they wanted you to be they were
worrying about the extent to which you
were challenging them
um you and I differed over what you
should have been challenging them on
where we did agree is that they should
be held to account and they didn't like
that and they were absolutely Overjoyed
when you left your job I also found uh
Richard that the one about Kobe I mean
at that time but still this is very
early on in the first wave you know one
of my good Morning Britain colleagues
Kate garraway her husband was critically
ill and remained so from covid so it was
no laughing matter for us if somebody
got covered in their 50s at the time
with no vaccine so I was pretty
concerned it turned out I didn't have it
then I did get it the following year but
um I didn't have it when I when I feared
I might and when it was really scary you
know
um certainly I wasn't laughing about it
this was a pretty serious moment and yet
the way they reacted even to vads pretty
actually pretty callous but that's what
we know is that actually they were they
were laughing about lots of things at a
time when they had successfully
terrified the nation and in those first
few weeks everybody no one knew what was
really going on but they seemed
remarkably relaxed about it that was
sort of May 2020 and the idea that they
could be wasting time in the nicest
possible way of is thinking about you
um they should have been focusing on the
science what's the latest data what are
the right decisions to make what are we
getting right what are we getting wrong
what do we need to change they shouldn't
be focusing about any individual at all
and I just find that whole thing
throughout this process extraordinary
well I mean what we'll see in tomorrow's
Telegraph is uh the the kind of gloating
and the gleefulness with which they
reacted when people were arrested or got
into trouble with the authorities for
supposed breaches of the lockdown
restrictions they were very keen for
example to see Nigel farage punished and
even went to the extent of trying to get
the home office involved in making sure
tough question for you on this